das sind die luftigsten und fluffigsten
Fladenbrote ever und die könnt ihr jetzt
ganz ganz einfach selber nachmachen ich
verrühre jetzt hier Hefe mit Wasser und
Mehl zu einem Vorteig und lass den dann
abgedeckt bei Raumtemperatur einen Tag
aufgehen ihr könnt das ganze auch ohne
Vortrag zubereiten dafür nehmt ihr dann
einfach ein bisschen mehr Hefe verknetet
dann die ganzen Zutaten in der
Küchenmaschine oder mit den Händen zu
einem glatten Teig lasst den Teig eine
Stunde aufgehen und portioniert dann 4
Teile daraus diese formt ihr dann so
schönen perfekten Kugeln deckt sie noch
mal ab und lasst sie gut aufgehen
bestreicht sie dann mit etwas Ei und
Milch mit Sesam bestreuen und backen und
daraus könnt ihr jetzt Panini machen
oder das ganze frisch verzehren